hello window winning winning hello and
welcome I just an read to read an
article where had winning in a solid
winning welcome to this video playing
poorly poorly from the US what is poorly
up to yeah he's playing this or she you
never know playing this funky line here
with long castles resembles a Sicilian
yeah I checked a check this line some
some time ago enter it's a it's a good
blitz weapon for white because it's um
this is kind of super aggressive stuff
objectively it's probably not that great
but it is some it is somewhat dangerous
for black so what is probably up to e5
is the idea night b5 I don't know if
this is an idea one day she is this h6
side h6 coming up if I go h 6 i'm a
threatening long castle CN in some way i
do ii am i think i do threaten that is
white no not be five
I'd be five I might even take you four
right may I can take you form so it's
kind of now whenever I am okay maybe
wide is just itching upon hoping for the
best but it also could be some kind of
real compensation we'll see let's take
it so what is why it's compensation
there must be something quick em
otherwise it's kind of just a pawn and
the center pond and okay
so where is the compensation here
and I don't see any actually
I would love to play book see a drug see
395 those kind of things that would
really enter game quite quickly if I can
get it in I don't think this line is
good to be honest this is to stop him I
tried dissolves myself once in a while
in the Blitz game just for quick
development but don't don't don't really
believe in it why it's 95 not good
what's the point okay first thing later
it should be seven or something oh it's
attacking my bishop
it is still tricky somewhat right it's
still somewhat tricky someone yes those
discovered to taxi an ID b5 coming
yes they would like to go back here
right 9b five their behalf i can
actually just take and be okay i mean i
don't like to give up the bishop pair
but i can get queens traded
hmm yeah so um let's get the Queen
somewhere else then just back him could
be could be the passive could be too
passive prenat for probably I wonder if
it is an idea than to just sacrifice the
exchange as a
let's do that I'm too fascinated by the
idea to not play it at the end gives me
really nice target on d3 and quite quite
a quite a fantastic bishop down so I
cannot take on on g2 it this looks
interesting attacking d three and three
day five stuff so Queen f5 to the I can
take here though we should f wait wait
wait wait my queen my queen first let's
take this first and then think about
this 93 no I can take here until I
wonder maybe maybe this one just take
this and then go to g4 I have h5 to
cement the bishop
hmm not sure I want to trade Bishop f5
maybe I don't have a good discovery but
okay just you just acted time morning
I'm not squandering away this
disadvantage again like I often do let's
use all the points all of them no please
note just just a bit of concentration of
InFocus place then I should be able to
do this okay
okay check check check check not a
stalemate if the check Lord heal me
please white [ __ ] pants on time okay so
yeah it was still extremely tricky this
is this game I mean he had to give up if
I know if he had to which he gave up
with the five he gave up that poem
pretty quickly I'm surprised that that
stock fish likes right here I mean up to
here it's certainly just just a
theoretical position I would assume at
least it looks very normal rd5
interesting a DM okay but how bad can
that be Knight f3 Bishop d7 and now
Queenie one interesting on 92 and that's
that's really interesting so probably
that d6 setup isn't all that greater
this was how I remembered it but yeah
this is really an this is a point it's a
little bit not typical this move but it
looks dangerous if I could do this let's
say and then well it's not that bad 94 I
come back and it doesn't seem like I'm
losing stuff tough so this one age six
and now we decided to ditch the pawn Jim
don't quite believe that this can be
enough but well we know we know the deal
in blitz it can be can be quite funky
long castles no that's not a move for me
castling right into this diagonal yeah
well I mean what is he doing it if you
move this is probably about it it might
be a better version here with a king in
but I mean it cannot be bad for me twin
6m maybe not strictly necessary each for
ya and now I decided to to take on d3
again this that's not a necessary move
but the motif is well known in those
structures and he I'm I'm actually I'm
having a pawn already so I'm not
surprised that stock which gives me an
advantage shared it wasn't strictly
necessary but it is the best attacking
piece that White House and the light
squares now are extremely weak without
the bishop also
the porn of course okay I computer
Bishop g2 no lab it now it seems to
reconsider yeah 95 I wasn't sure the
night felt like an attacking piece to me
potentially wit and probably you should
be should take at them and then it took
me home how to see that the Queen was
actually meeting but this is now
probably a very very good ending we
should be too was stronger yeah but ok I
just take everything and it should be it
should be fine with 220 points ok so I'm
happy that I got this um converted at
the end but it's interesting to see the
the opening there I was thinking that
this is a good setup this is this is
some Queen a five maybe I should maybe
d5 is better it looks a bit
counterintuitive to play d5 here against
this hmm Bishop c4 funky lately no d55
interesting right interesting stuff
nothing i have a check thoroughly ok
guys thanks for watching